our next guest is a very talented
musician whose song kings and queens
has been stuck in all our heads for the
last year her latest single is called my
head in my heart and it's also on the
album
heaven and hell clearly she enjoys a
good conjunction y'all
please welcome ava max everybody
[Music]
hello again i know we can't hug uh hot
air balloons are like my favorite things
you know i've never been on one but i
haven't living through my shirt right
now
i told my friends okay funny story i
love going on them but i told my friends
we were in like scotland or ireland i
can't remember i think scotland and
they were like okay we'll do we'll do
and they're afraid and literally landed
so hard something happened and it fell
oh my god that's terrifying it's like
the one going you're gonna love it
anyway um well the last time that i saw
you we talked about how you got started
but i didn't know your mama was a singer
yes she has a beautiful voice um she can
out sing me
any day she is an incredible operatic
voice you know
she never fulfilled it fully her dream
because she had kids but um
and she was you know an immigrant to the
states and she got to work immediately
because they didn't have money when they
came to the states and they didn't have
jobs
so you know she dedicated her life to
her kids so you were born in wisconsin
but so
where were your parents from albania i
feel like there's a lot of great singers
from albania like there's
you there's rita ora there's dua lipa
there's bb rexa
there's a lot of singers what's
happening there i don't know what's
happening
yeah i don't know but my entire family
grandma grandpa
and all unbelievably ugly
you're also all very hard to look at so
that's that's yeah i'm like what's
happening
there what's why very good makeup good
water
like what's happening like but is it a
passionate
is it a pain i think it's in our blood
it's very passionate we're very
passionate we're kind of like
you know like we use our hands a lot
we're very like um we kind of sing our
words in a way
everyone tells me oh you sing kind of
when you talk
and i'm just like i don't know but maybe
you just said i don't know
but maybe i wasn't always meant to sing
but it's awesome though i didn't realize
how many people were from
elbati i was like wow all their
relatives i thought that was interesting
i love it they're like basically my
sisters
yeah i feel like they're like my musical
sisters yeah it's a good bunch
y'all would be the most amazing girl
group ever um well do you remember the
very first time that you ever tried to
write a song because you're a writer as
well not just a singer i do remember
um there's a few instances one um i
wrote a song called treat me like a lady
at 13.
at 13. and what did i know you were
hitting puberty
what did i know though so i was way
ahead of my female empowerment game back
then
yes like i knew what i was going to
write about even way back then with that
subconsciously
you noticed something was wrong early on
i didn't like didn't like the way
women i was like looking at were treated
and i
wrote a song called treat me like a lady
like who does that at 13. very strange
but i i don't really remember it i just
remember the title and it being very
like soulful it was kind of like an r b
song yeah and i just went in my first
songs were like that too
yeah i think that was the 90s influence
really for me too yes the best
yes all the best r b wow well your new
single is my head and my heart so what
were you going through was it a
relationship kind of thing
or a friendship or you know i'm always
living my art
it's very strange do you ever find that
you're like you feel like you're
like fortune telling and like you'll
write a song and then it happens
did that ever happen because that yeah
it's insanity yeah and i'm starting and
did i project it
i exactly i talk about these things in
therapy
i think i need to too because i put it
out there and then it happens to me and
then i'm like oh wow life
imitates art yeah in a way and and it
makes sense because energy is everything
what you put out there
you get back and yeah and so yeah all my
songs are kind of
me right now i am a torn torn kind of
per i'm always like this or that like i
never know what i truly
want in relationships you know and
that's just what i think that we
don't maybe you don't have to know that
maybe it's like a process like that you
learn and it's always going to be
different with different people
exactly i feel like you'll know when you
know right when it's
well i don't know right i don't know
anymore let's just say that
is it true that your mom you said she
studied opera right did you ever
do any of that kind of stuff with her
did she ever you know i know
in the house where you were like let me
sing with her i always sang pop she
always sang opera so his chest my voice
and hers was like all head voice and i
could never do what she did
it's very mariah carey i feel like her
mom was an opera singer so weird
she did pop yeah yeah yeah yeah we also
have the same birthmark
i know that sounds good you do i'm not
the fact that you know that doesn't
sound weird at all
i love mariah carey i love ryan i do too
i did my number one
and so i remember seeing a picture i
think the butterfly record or something
and she was like
she was pretty much like just a bra like
pretty much yeah it was like tan
yeah like everything was dead like brown
and basically her birthmark right
underneath her belly button
same one wow and our mothers are
operating mariah
i didn't know she was like ultimate
she's very nice
i love i've run into her a few times she
was so nice in a way her songs taught me
how to sing i would be in my basement
singing her songs over and over and over
she's one of mine as well
yeah the best and especially just her
her octaves like are insane
yes like shut up i'm like why are you
talking yeah
well ava's single is called my head and
my heart it's on her heaven and hell
album check it out everybody you're
going to check it out
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
[Music]